all right we want to let people know
about protests in allentown pennsylvania
after a police officer was caught on
camera placing his knee
on a man's neck while attempting to
restrain him some demonstrators say the
video
reminded them of george floyd's deadly
encounter with police in minnesota so we
should warn you that the footage this
time is once again
possibly disturbing to some viewers
police officers
observed the man vomiting and staggering
in the street outside a hospital on
saturday and that's when police
attempted
to restrain the man who they say was
non-compliant
the man was later treated at the
hospital and released
demonstrators in downtown allentown
demanded answers
allentown's police chief told protesters
the department
is investigating the officer's use of
force now it happens to be that earlier
this month the police department
released its use of force policy
which bans choke holds and neck
restraints the incident is also being
reviewed by the county's district
attorney anthony we're looking at video
like that again